let's say that you've got a bag and in
that bag you put a bunch of marbles so
let's say you put 50 of these magenta
marbles so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 I'm not going
to draw all of them but you get the
general idea there are going to be 50
magenta marbles 15 magenta marbles and
there's also going to be 50 blue marbles
so 50 50 blue marbles and what you do is
you have these 100 marbles in there half
of the magenta half of them blue and
before picking a marble out and you're
going to be blindfolded when you pick a
marble out you shake the bag you shake
the bag really good too - so you think
mix them up a little bit and so if you
were to say well theoretically what is
the probability if you stuck your hand
in and you're not looking what is the
probability of picking of picking a
magenta I have to feel the need to write
the word magenta in magenta what is the
probability of picking a magenta marble
well theoretically there's a hundred
equally likely possibilities there's 100
marbles in the bag and 50 of them
involve picking a magenta so 50 out of
100 and this is the same thing as a 1/2
probability so you could say well
theoretically there is a 1/2 probability
I just did the math if you say these are
100 equally likely possibilities 50 of
them are picking magenta now let's say
you actually start doing the experiment
so you literally take a bag with 50
magenta marbles 50 blue marbles and then
you start picking you start picking the
marbles and then you see what marble
color you picked and you put it back in
and then you do it again and so let's
say that after let's say that after what
every time you you put your hand in the
bag and you take something out of the
out of the bag and you observe what it
is what we're gonna call that an
experiment so after after 10 experiments
10 experiments after 10 experiments
let's say that you have picked out
seven magenta seven magenta and three
blue and three blue so does this cause
is this is it strange that after ten it
out of the first ten experiments you
haven't picked out exactly half of them
being magenta you've picked out seven
magenta and then the other three were
blue well no this is definitely a
reasonable thing if the true probability
of picking out of magenta is one-half
it's definitely possible that you could
still pick out seven magenta did that
just happen to be what your fingers
touched and this isn't a lot of
experiments it's completely reasonable
that out of ten yeah you could have a
any other we later on in statistics we
could all define these things in in more
detail but there's enough variation in
where you might pick that you're not
going to always get especially with only
ten experiments you're not definitely
going to get exactly one half you can
you you know instead of having five
magenta it's completely reasonable to
have seven magenta so this really
wouldn't cause me a lot of pause I still
wouldn't say hey I still wouldn't
question what I did here when I
calculated this theoretical probability
but let's say and you let's say you have
a lot of time on your hands and let's
say after let's say after 10,000 trials
here after 10,000 experiments and
remember experiment you're sticking your
hand in the bag without looking your
fingers kind of feeling around picks out
a marble and you observe the marble and
you record what you found and so let's
say after 10,000 experiments you get
7,000 7,000 magenta actually let me do
slightly different numbers so let me
make it even more extreme let's say you
get 8,000 8,000 magenta and you have
2,000 blue 2,000 2,000 blue now this is
interesting because here you're what
you're what you're seeing experimentally
seems to be very different and now you
have a large number of trials right over
here not just 10 10 it's completely
reasonable it
hey you know I get seven magenta and
three balloons at a five and five now
you've done ten thousand ten thousand
it's definitely you know you would have
expected if this was the true
probability you would have expected that
half of these would have been magenta
only five thousand magenta and five
thousand blue and you had eight thousand
magenta now this is within the realm of
possibility if the true probability of
picking and magenta is 1/2 but it's not
it's very unlikely that you would have
gotten this result with this many
experiments this many trials if the true
probabilities 1/2 here your experimental
probability your experimental
probability is showing look out of out
of 10,000 trials
let's see let me write that here
experimental probability experimental
probability here is you had 10,000
trials and or 10,000 experiments I guess
you could say and you and in 8,000 of
them you got a magenta marble and so
this is going to be 80% or 8/10 so 80%
so there seems to be a difference here
and the reason why I would take this
more seriously is that you had a lot of
trials here you did this
10,000 times if the true probability was
1/2 it's very low likelihood that you
would have gotten this many magenta so
when you think Michael okay well what
did I what's going on here what are
possible explanations for this this I
wouldn't have fretted about after 10
experiments not a big deal but after
10,000 this would have caused me pause
say well why would this happen I mixed
up the bag every time and there are some
different possibilities maybe the blue
marbles are slightly heavier and so when
you shake the bag up enough the blue
marbles settle to the bottom and you're
more likely to put pick a magenta marble
maybe the blue marbles have a slightly
different texture to them in which case
maybe they slip out of your hands or
there they're less likely to be gripped
on and so you're more likely to pick a
magenta so I don't know the explanation
I don't know what's going on in that bag
but if if I thought theoretically that
the probability should be 1/2 because
1/2
the marbles are magenta but I'm seeing
it through my experiments that 80% of
what I'm picking out especially if I did
10,000 of if I did this 10,000 times
well this is this is going to cause me
some pause I would really start to think
about whether it's truly equally likely
for me to pick out a red magenta versus
a blue something else must be going on